joining us now on the programme tom
persliv the minister for justice and
tackling illegal migration i'm mr
president great to have you on the
program this morning and look i wonder
if we can just start from from from
first principles what is the rationale
for essentially forcibly repatriating
people who arrive in this country
seeking asylum to rwanda for processing
so what is absolutely clear is that it
is completely unacceptable to continue
to be in this situation where people pay
evil people smugglers putting their
lives in their hands with the only
consideration being to make a profit for
those people smugglers and all the risks
that that involves we saw in november
the terrible consequences when this goes
wrong we cannot continue to have that
happen and of course there's a moral
imperative to take action that's
precisely what we're doing through our
new plan for immigration and through the
steps that we set out yesterday and i
think this new economic development
partnership with ruanda is an important
intervention one of a number of
interventions to take action to address
this issue and i think it will help to
shift the dial
but just in terms of the rationale that
we have had from from both your boss at
the home office pretty patel but also
from the prime minister i keep being
told that the majority of people who are
arriving on boats such as the ones we're
showing our viewers right now are
economic migrants i'm just wondering
what the source is for that
i'm afraid there's terrible interruption
on the line
so i can't hear your question i'm very
sorry it's all right minister i'll try
and ask again what is the evidence base
for the assertion from the prime
minister and the home secretary that the
majority the overwhelming majority
according to pretty patel or people
arriving in small boats are economic
migrants
so what is very clear is that around 70
percent of the individuals who are
arriving are single adult males but my
point is this that nobody should be
coming to our country via small boat
whether that be males whether that be
women whether that be children everybody
is leaving what are fundamentally safe
countries
there are perfectly functioning asylum
systems in france and in other eu
countries and people should be using
them when they're in those countries
rather than making these perilously
unsafe journeys so we have to take steps
to address this that's precisely what we
are doing and i think that this is an
important intervention that dramatically
shifts the dynamic whilst also providing
opportunities and sanctuary in rwanda
for individuals who wish to have that
sure and i'm sorry to labor the point
minister but again the prime minister
and the home secretary have both claimed
that part of the rationale for this is
that the majority of people arriving in
small boats are are economic migrants
i'm just again asking where the data is
on that we've asked the home office for
it plenty of times it's never been
produced indeed the refugee council
suggests actually a significant majority
of people who arrive in small boats are
actually successful in their asylum
claims that they're not economic
migrants at all
the key principle here is that nobody
should be getting in a small boat to
come to the united kingdom we quite
rightly have a rich and proud history in
this country of providing sanctuary for
thousands of people over the years and
you look at recent events with ukraine
and with afghanistan where we've
established bespoke schemes and we'll
continue to do that but what we can't
have and what we can't accept is people
putting their lives in the hands of
these evil criminal gangs that's why we
think it's important to take these steps
and that's why we're pursuing this with
digger we think this is an important
intervention that we're making as part
of the much wider package of reforms
that we're introducing
yeah i i i will note that again i have
asked that question and the evidence
base has not been brought forward so
perhaps the government can stop
maintaining that the majority of people
coming across the channel are economic
migrants without giving us the the the
detail in all of this but whilst i think
plenty of people will agree with you
that something needs to be done about
the problems in the channel with those
small boats i mean how long before this
this scheme gets started i mean before
it gets started aren't we likely to see
actually an increase in the number of
people heading over the channel because
you've just announced that at some point
ill-defined in the future there will be
a more draconian system in place isn't
the likelihood that for the next few
weeks we're going to see increased
numbers because of the announcement that
your boss made
well that of course lends itself to the
suggestion that the policy that we have
announced will be successful in terms of
deterring people from making these
journeys in the first place um the fact
is that there are 80 million people
numbered you can see that you have
driven up numbers
into the united kingdom
you can see though that you have will
drive up numbers for the next for the
next period however long it is until
this scheme comes in because you have
announced essentially draconian measures
further down the line you accept that
no the point that i would make is that
we are determined to get on and deliver
this policy as quickly as possible
without needless delay um that is our
determined position and of course
there's been the negotiations with
rwanda which have been concluded with
the signing of this economic development
partnership we are now getting into the
state where we implement this policy
quickly anybody who's arrived in the
united kingdom from the 1st of january
is in scope to be relocated to rwanda if
they've arrived through illegal means
that is of course an important point to
get across so if you've arrived since
then it could well be that you are
transferred as part of this arrangement
can we just ask
why rwanda i mean how safe is that
country i mean you know luckily i mean
they haven't had a genocide in almost 30
years which is great but the record on
human rights particularly lgb is is
pretty sketchy human rights watch report
published last year found evidence that
the rwandan authorities had detained
over a dozen gay and transgender people
ahead of a june 2021 conference this is
all taking place presumably whilst your
department has been negotiating with
rwanda
we have seen i have to say some
appalling stereotypes thrown around in
the last 24 hours since this
announcement
the foreign office the foreign office
travel advice for heading to rwanda
reads this homosexuality remains frowned
upon by many it's not illegal but it can
be frowned upon lgbt individuals can
experience discrimination and abuse
including from local authorities that is
the advice given to gay people in this
country by the foreign office just
around the corner from you
the fact is that rwanda has made huge
strides forward over the last three
decades um it has a female majority
parliament it has an anti-discrimination
law that runs right through its
constitution and it's also just worth
making the point that the unhcr
themselves place refugees in rwanda as
part of
their schemes which of course is
providing sanctuary to them and they
have a rich and proud history rather
like we do in this country of providing
sanctuary to people who need it but but
also let me just make a further point so
i think this is crucial in all of this
that in terms of individuals being
considered for relocation to rwanda that
will be managed on a case-by-case basis
taking proper account of everybody's
circumstances before any such transfer
happens that is the right and proper way
of managing this responsibly making sure
and the key criteria is this that it is
safe for them
allow me perhaps and to to draw a
comparison or or
between two two things that are going on
at the moment and many people are doing
this at the moment you know even if we
accepted the majority of people coming
across the channel were economic
migrants which we don't there are
hundreds of people the other side of the
channel who want to pay money to come to
this country to try and earn and indeed
to pay money to the exchequer compare
and contrast that with the wife of the
chancellor who left downing street
because people had the temerity to
criticize her for paying 30 000 pounds
to the government to avoid paying tax
here
um i don't think that um
the two things are comparable and the
bottom line here is very clear that
nobody should be paying evil people
smugglers to make dangerous crossings of
the english channel i couldn't be
clearer about that point
no one doubts that no one doubts that
the question is whether or not this is
the best way in which to do it i mean in
parallel to all of this of course we now
understand that the royal navy will be
taking responsibility for the channel
now despite the fact that we've seen you
know historic cuts to the fleet ever
since the conservatives came into power
in 2010 but surely the broader point
about the involvement of the royal navy
is that border force and by proxy your
department can't do the job
i categorically reject that this is a
issue that is of huge concern to the
british people there is no one single
intervention that will resolve this of
itself and it's right that we have a
cross-government response to this
challenge
and actually the royal navy have an
awful lot of expertise um that they can
bring to bear through the command and
control structure that is now in place
adding additional resource to this work
and of course by introducing the
interventions that we are it is likely
that the dynamic will change what we've
previously had until now is that
individuals have wanted to be picked up
and have wanted to be spotted because
they've wanted to enter the uk asylum
system what isn't acceptable and i know
this from speaking to people in kent is
beach landings happening people turning
up there's a border security a risk
associated with that as well and so i
think adding that capacity drawing on
that royal navy experience and expertise
is actually important as we get to grips
with this issue get this under control
we cannot have uncontrolled migration
into this country in the way that we've
seen of late
minister final question can you
guarantee that this scheme will ever be
introduced
we are absolutely determined as the
prime minister set out yesterday to
introduce this scheme to operationalize
it this is a big step forward through
this economic development partnership
and helping to tackle this challenge
that we are facing whilst also working
with rwanda to provide opportunities for
people who are relocated there and the
status quo just isn't acceptable while
people are making these dangerous
journeys risking their lives there is an
imperative on us to act we have to
change that dynamic and that's precisely
what we're doing and the pm has said
very clearly that we will do everything
necessary to make this happen
at tom very busy day for you no doubts
we'll let you crack on with it thanks
very much for joining us